Some of the events that we've listed
suggest that we need to add additional
state machines, sub-machines, to our
set of concurrently executing machines.
Typically, these correspond
to internal timers.
So you think about it,
the clock radio has some timers in it,
for example, with the snooze button.
You know it has to time ten minutes
before it turns itself off.
And those timers, even though they
aren't directly or explicitly
visible to the user, do effect things
which are visible to the user.
So, we're going to have to model them.
So, the question then arises
as to which ones those are,
how do you come up with
that list of things?
And one way of doing that
might be to consider events
eight through eleven which are the
events that correspond to depressing and
releasing the wake and sleep buttons.
So think for a minute about what is
going on when those buttons are pressed,
and presumably, then, the user is also
pressing the hour and minute buttons.
>> And you want me to design another
state machine to represent this?
>> Well,
first think what the radio has to do
to deal with those things, and
see if that if that doesn't then suggest
that we need to keep track
of some history somehow, and
if that then suggests that we need
to have another state machine there.
>> Okay.
So, I think, based on the buttons,
say, none of the buttons are pressed,
talking about the wake button,
and the sleep button.
>> Right.
>> It seems like that needs to be
represented by some kind of state,
say, nothing, or none, or something.
And based on that state, your other
machines are going to act a certain way.
Like when you press the hour and minute
button, the rest of your state machines
for adjusting the display and so on and
so forth, will act a certain way.
But then you have a state where
the wake button is pressed, so
that's it's own state.
And based on it being in that state,
your other machines
will act a certain way.
>> So, while we're pressing that
wake button we are in a state.
Okay?
>> Yes.
>> And that state then allows
us to press the hour button.
Okay?
So,
pressing that hour button while we we're
in that state has a different effect
than pressing it when
we're not in that state.
Okay?
So, let's see what such a state
machine might look like.